erschienen 1 440 seelen dorf ruhig
gelegen
in rauer landschaft rund um
durchlöcherte alb in die welt der
tunnels und rede die gänge tauchen
derzeit künstler ein für die
sommerausstellung des hauses für kunst
uri wird gegossen gemalte zimmer in
einem ehemaligen munitionslager heute
ein ort für kreativität für einen
werkstattbesuch angereist die rektorin
und kuratorin barbara zürcher
ich bin wahnsinnig gespannt was jetzt
mit den drei künstler unterkünften
passiert ist in den größen in einem
atelier wo sind jetzt wird verdichtet in
dem kunst und das ist großartig das geht
ganz andere dynamik
erste station das dusch eine 5 karin
wellisch lee und guido reichlich lassen
sich gerne auf reisen durch fremde
länder inspirieren
für einmal nun von göschenen das duo
will nicht zuletzt unseren täglichen
umgang mit energie beleuchten
der basistunnel das gefeierter
jahrhundert bauwerk soll tag für tag so
viel strom benötigen wie eine stadt mit
22.000 einwohner
die idee ist dass er jetzt mit
ausgestellt wird das luftfahrzeug im
sasso san gottardo der wahl genfer peter
stoffe aufgewachsen in appenzell geprägt
hat ihn der alpstein er denke in berge
so der maler der unermüdlich schicht für
schicht auf und teils wieder ab trägt
das tunnel thema dürfte stoffe liegen er
malt grundsätzlich nur bei dunkelheit
station 3 wachs grüters jetzt auch sie
werden auf den gotthardpass auftaucht
soziales
und zugleich mystisch bisher grüter die
ist seine skulpturen aus beton für das
ergebnis entscheidend ist die füllmenge
aus erfahrung werden so die
unterschiedlichsten charaktere zwischen
75 und 250 kilo wiegen die köpfe und
büssten die geburt dieser geschöpfe ein
akt der körpereinsatz und
fingerspitzengefühl fordert
wenn man sich noch vor uns auf so dass
schon subversiv dieser er taucht ja
sieht extrem erleichtert dass ich meine
das funktioniert seht ihr komplizierte
installationen und was ich ganz schön
finden sich märkte künstlichen
profitiert das finde ich toll an dem
projekt kunst am berg die schon im
entstehen fasziniert